foreign
[Music]
the biggest planet in the solar system
has gone Rogue and now it's heading
straight toward Earth
you have 30 days till this gas giant
wipes us all out
what speeds would Jupiter be traveling
at
what kind of Havoc would it reek along
the way
and is there any way we could survive
getting eaten by a planetary Pac-Man
this is what if and here's what would
happen if Jupiter collided with Earth
in our night sky Jupiter appears a lot
like a bright star
from our Earthly point of view only
Venus and the moon are brighter
but something strange is going on
588 million kilometers away
Jupiter has ramped up its speed to 225
kilometers per second
that's 15 times faster than its usual
orbital velocity
so now this gas giant 11 times larger
and 317 times heavier than Earth is on
the loose and it's going to speed right
at us until it's filled up the entire
night sky
but don't worry you could already be
dead long before those 30 days are up
as it moved toward Earth Jupiter would
first pass through the asteroid belt
this region between Jupiter and Mars
consists of hundreds of thousands of
Rocky bodies ranging from Tiny dust
particles to asteroids almost 1 000
kilometers in width
but none of these would do anything to
slow down the gas giant the average
distance between these asteroids is
about equal to seven Jupiters in a row
so there's a chance the planet could
pass through completely unscathed
and in our night sky Jupiter would now
look double its usual size
which doesn't seem like a whole lot to
make everyone panic but that doesn't
mean it wouldn't cause a little bit of
chaos on his trip
you see Jupiter is vital to our solar
system and to life on Earth
it acts as a gatekeeper to our cozy
planetary neighborhood protecting us
from being bombarded with giant
life-ending asteroids all the time
why well because Jupiter's gravitational
pull is massive about four times
stronger than Earth's
this strong pull redirects asteroids
that could be on a collision course with
us
and this is good news for you because
even one asteroid as small as five
kilometers across could end life on
Earth as you know it
just like what happened to the dinosaurs
around 66 million years ago
but if Jupiter suddenly started heading
toward the center of the solar system it
could send many dangerous space rocks
our way if one of them smashed into
Earth
you might not live long enough to see
Jupiter swallowers
but for the sake of our hypothetical
scenario let's keep you alive
while sending asteroids on a collision
course with Earth Jupiter could also
pick up a new moon or two the asteroid
belt is home to the only dwarf planet in
the inner solar system series it has
about 25 percent of the total mass of
the entire belt maybe this dwarf planet
would join the 79 other moons that make
up Jupiter's very faint ring system
next stop would be Mars and now Jupiter
would appear almost four times larger
than usual from Earth
now while the red planet could be lucky
enough to avoid being obliterated by a
head-on impact with Jupiter it might not
make it out untouched
maybe the newly added Moon series would
slam into it
and this wouldn't be Mars's first rodeo
either about 700 million years after the
formation of our solar system
a huge asteroid even larger than series
collided with Mars
that Collision tore Away part of the
Martian Hemisphere and the debris from
that asteroid started orbiting the red
planet eventually forming its Two Moons
Phobos and demos
these moons still orbit Mars today
now at 16 million kilometers away
Jupiter would be closing in on the home
stretch
from Earth you'd see it bright and clear
as large as the Moon
and from this point on you'd start to
feel some of the effects of Jupiter's
powerful magnetic field
this field is the largest object in the
solar system and it's 18
000 times more powerful than Earth's
it would be so strong that it could trap
charged particles and accelerate them
these particles would damage electronics
in our passing spacecraft and they could
potentially penetrate Earth's atmosphere
and magnetic field
and that would be really bad news
now you were lucky to avoid one of these
planet-killing asteroid collisions but
now you and everyone else on planet
Earth would start to suffer from severe
radiation sickness first you'd be
incapacitated by nausea diarrhea and
vomiting you'd also feel anxiety
confusion and could lose consciousness
after a few torturous hours you'd start
to feel okay
but then the final stage would kick in
you'd experience Tremors and convulsions
before ending up in a coma or worse
if somehow you survived this the
ultimate end would draw nearer and
nearer
now only 2 million kilometers away the
Great Red Spot would be the same size as
the moon and the planet itself would
appear eight times larger than that rock
above us
Earth would now be caught in a violent
game of tug of war between Jupiter and
the Sun
this could cause tidal heating all
around our planet
Earth could become a hell hole riddled
with earthquakes and volcanic eruptions
that would spew sulfur dioxide gases
into space
all the while Jupiter would be making
its Final Approach
now as close as the Moon it would occupy
40 times more space in our night sky and
as it crashes into Earth the atmospheres
of both planets would compress this
would rapidly increase the temperature
causing everything on Earth including
the air itself to burst into flames and
in this colossal Inferno Earth would
burn up in Jupiter's atmosphere until we
fuse with the gas giant forever
I guess you could call us pretty unlucky
to be the only planet swallowed up by
Jupiter
I wonder what would happen if Jupiter
swallowed up all the others too
well that's a story
for another
what if